hello this is steve kaufman and hello
siberia
this is in response
to an e to a
youtube video
that
i received from an english teacher in
siberia who asked me to do a video
to explain to his students 14 year old
students
why they should learn
english so i'm going to speak slowly i'm
going to make this video in english
and then i'm going to make another video
on the same subject in russian
for these 14 year old students
somewhere in siberia
first of all let me say
i have been to siberia
i was in habarovsk in
1975 and i flew from khabarovs to moscow
and it was a beautiful day and the scope
the size
of siberia is
unbelievable i was my nose
was glued to the window i was
watching siberia basically as we flew
over these vast
forests it's a place that i would love
to visit
now
why should a 14 year old
living in siberia learn english
my first answer is that a person living
in siberia or canada or japan or brazil
should not only learn one foreign
language he or she should learn several
more than one foreign language
and the reason is simple
if i take my own case
i
have worked now i mean i'm 67 years old
so i'm quite a bit older than
you 14 year olds in siberia
i have seen a lot more in my life and i
know many things now at age 67 that i
didn't know when i was 14.
now in my own case i worked in fact i
still work i've worked for over 40 years
and i have been i would think fairly
successful
in terms of
you know what i wanted to do in my life
uh i have a nice family i have two sons
i have five grandchildren i live in a
nice house i travel when i want
if my wife and i want to go out to a
nice restaurant we go out if we want to
go on holidays we go on holidays in
other words i would say that i am quite
comfortable
i consider that whatever success i have
had
in my job in my work
has come from knowing
languages
and i will go through the languages that
i learned
that
more opportunities have come to me
because i knew a lot of languages
than i would otherwise ever had have had
a chance
to to
you know to to get at
so
languages means opportunities in my case
i learned french and that's why i was
accepted into the canadian diplomatic
service i learned chinese
i learned japanese that enabled me to
set up my own company selling lumber to
japan
i then went and studied spanish and
other languages and that helped me do
business in europe it helped me meet
people it helped me
increase my range of contacts it helped
me create personal connections with
people so that's just on the business
side
however
in the last 10 years or so i have
learned
other languages that have nothing to do
with my business like russian
and so later on i will do a video in
russian and every language that i learn
gives me so much enjoyment because i was
able to go to saint petersburg i was
able to go to moscow
meet people
have dinner with people talk with people
visit the theater go here go there
understand everything that's going on
it gives you a tremendous feeling of
satisfaction
so
in russian
i like certain
movies i like certain
writers
i like
uh certain music i have friends who are
russian so i have things that i like in
russian and that
the ability to speak russian and to
understand russian gives me tremendous
enjoyment so all of these things are the
same for you
but
more so
because whether we like it or not
english is the most useful language in
the world
we may wish that russian were more of an
international language or french or
chinese or esperanto but
the real situation is that wherever you
go in the world if you go to japan if
you go to china if you go to
germany if you go to brazil
the common language
is english now why is this important if
you live in siberia
and i've seen the distances in siberia
and there's probably not an
english-speaking person for many
thousands of kilometers in any
direction because today
we live in
a very connected world
so that even if you are in the middle of
siberia
it is very easy for you to connect with
people
with movies with music
with
culture with
whatever you want via the internet
instantly in english or in spanish or in
chinese or whatever language you're
interested in but english is the most
useful because
more people speak english
as a second language i'm not talking
about native speakers in the united
states or
great britain or canada i'm talking
about people who use english as a second
language as not their own language but a
language to communicate with other
people who also use it as a second
language so english is the international
means of communication
and even if you live
in siberia
you are going to have contact lots of
contact with people from other countries
and in order for that
interaction
to be
meaningful
you need to speak english now these are
things that you don't understand at age
14 or some of you do and some of you
don't
now i would further give you the advice
that in order
to learn english you have to like
learning english i like learning russian
i like learning other languages czech or
french or korean you have to like it
that doesn't mean that you have to like
everything about
english culture or american culture that
you have to like all american music you
have to like all english or australian
or canadian or american people you meet
you don't have to like them all you have
to find something you like
music
movies
books
some people a friend
you have to find something to like
and then
what you want to do what you need to do
is to
devote yourself to cultivating that
relationship with the book with the
person with the music
and not worry too much about your
grammar
about speaking correctly
these things don't matter so much
most people who use english as a second
language
make mistakes
the important thing is to be able to
communicate
because
we live in this world today
we are sharing this world all seven
billion or so people who live in the
world we are sharing this world at the
same time we are alive at the same time
and the ability to connect with people
who are sharing this moment
in this enormous history
of the world to connect with other
people who live in different countries
your neighbor in china or
uh someone in the southern hemisphere in
africa or whatever the ability to
connect with these people and with their
culture and their way of thinking
is tremendously enriching to your life
and
probably it will enable you to be
more successful because through your
language you will be
able to access more opportunities more
connections
not because you get a job as a
translator but because
if you are somewhere traveling and
you're sitting in a plane beside someone
who is from turkey and
if you have a common language you can
speak and from that you will meet people
who will be helpful to you
in your life or in your lives or people
who will in other ways enrich your lives
because they will become friends so
i have done this now a great long speech
in english
and if i remember what i said i will try
to say some of the same things in
russian thank you for listening